empty streets in nepal's capital as a
two-week lockdown is imposed to limit
the spread of coronavirus
it's the second wave to hit the country
infections have surged and more than
half are in the capital kathmandu
hospitals are seeing more cases in a
shorter span of time
the second wave is more potent with more
young people and children infected
as health workers struggle to contain
the growing number of patients
experts fear that thousands may have
caught the mutant variant strains
emerging out of neighbouring india
thousands of workers from nepal have
left their jobs in indian cities
where korvid-19 is spiraling out of
control they're arriving here in
nepalese towns by the border and that's
creating a major health crisis
it's like a mini india if the situation
was similar in the capital which has a
dense population
it would be difficult to cope with the
existing health infrastructure
more than 300 000 people in nepal have
got covet 19.
90 have recovered over 3 000 people have
died
as daily cases surge experts warn that
the epidemic
could overwhelm nepal's fragile health
system if the country is unable to break
the chain of transmission in time
nepal's health authorities have
repeatedly appealed to the public to
wear masks
avoid crowds and to maintain social
distance but recent political rallies
and religious festivals
have helped fuel the spread of the
disease thousands rushed to leave the
capital after the lockdown was announced
i'm waiting at the bus stop for a seat
out of kathmandu
it's crowded the situation is difficult
i'd rather be back in my village
where i can make ends meet health
authorities fear this exodus
could spread the virus in villages
across nepal keep them
out of control the situation is not out
of control
but kovet is spreading and cases are
rising we are prioritizing our efforts
to contain kovid emergencies
nepal launched a vaccination campaign in
january giving doses from india and
china to nearly 2 million people
but with a population of 28 million and
limited access to vaccines
nepal will have to seek support from the
international community
to prevent the epidemic from spiraling
out of control
ramyata limbu al-jazeera kathmandu